beck annonce un virage dans son approche
internationale la diplomatie québécoise
se rappeler à partir de maintenant à
favoriser davantage une action
économique l'objectif c'est d'augmenter
les investissements des exportations
favorisées l'immigration l'innovation
l'éducation également on en parle ce
soir avec nadine giraud ministre des
relations internationales et de la
francophonie bonsoir madame giro bon
sang mais c'est finir bienvenue à
l'émission ce soir ou parlez nous un peu
de ce qui change dans le fond de la
politique internationale moi j'avais
l'impression que ça devait être axé
nécessairement sur l'ailier économique
qu'est ce qui est différent
en fait ce qui change beaucoup dans la
politique versus la halle à dix on est
en national du québec gars est la
politique internationale du québec c'est
qu'on a pris les les commentaires on
appris aussi toutes les études qu'on
avait faite et on a ajouté à ça le côté
économique wallon que l'agro les gros
changements les grosses modifications
entre les deux c'est vraiment que on
veut faire de la diplomatie économique
en plus de la diplomatie d'influencé on
ne fait pas déjà les délégations ne font
pas déjà sur présentement aider les
délégations font un peu d'économies
comme on en faisait un peu mais il le
faisait à travers beaucoup d'autres
activités et c'était pas le focus nous
ce qu'on veut faire c'est vraiment avoir
le focus principal sur l'économique tout
en continuant à faire la diplomatie
d'influencé comme on l'a fait parce que
c'est important moi je compare toujours
à une maison avec une fondation la
fondation de la maison c'est vraiment
tout ce qu'on fait au niveau influente
influence du placide influences qu'on
doit continuer à faire mais on ajoute
les étages supérieurs qui est vraiment
laitages économique dont la diplomatie
économique
pourquoi on a besoin de faire ça les
entreprises font leur travail des
missions des chambres de commerce et
investissement québec international
pourquoi il faut transformer en quelque
sorte le rôle diplomatique de nos
représentations en fait ce qu'on veut
faire c'est l'objectif principal du
gouvernement c'est d'augmenter le niveau
de vie des québécois et d'avoir vraiment
des postes plus intéressant des jobs
plus payants comme dirait le premier
ministre pour faire ça il faut qu'on
exporte davantage qu'on connaît nos
entreprises à exporter
il faut qu'on aille chercher des
investisseurs à l'étranger qui vont
venir investir ici et créer des emplois
plus payant et pour faire ça on a un
réseau de représentations à l'extérieur
ikki à ses contacts inquiète les
contacts à l'international et compte
dont on peut bénéficier et on va les
utiliser comme effet de levier pour
justement aller faire ça vous voulez de
doubler les investissements étrangers
ici cela dit il ya déjà beaucoup
d'investissements étrangers ici oui on
manque surtout de travailleurs dans le
fond oui en fait c'est pour ça que les
cinq priorités dont on a parlé
aujourd'hui à l'intérieur de la vision
on a dit on a les fondements qui sont
vraiment la langue la culture notre
identité culturelle
on a aussi tout ce qui est au niveau de
la proximité avec les régions va se
rapprocher des régions et le troisième
s'est passée la diplomatie d'influencé à
la diplomatie économique et à
l'intérieur de ça on a vraiment on veut
vraiment augmenter l'activité économique
au québec l'action économique à
l'étranger aussi et on va le faire à
partir de cinq priorités et ses
priorités la touche vraiment à des
niveaux très spécial mais quand on parle
à des gens d'affaires je pense à louis
têtu qui nous dit souvent à québec le
cliché coveo qui dit attention l'on
donne des crédits d'impôts à des
investisseurs étrangers qui viennent ici
et finalement on est dans une rareté de
main-d'oeuvre ils vont chercher les
travailleurs y sont avantagés est ce
qu'on s'en va vers ça davantage
en fait ce qu'on va faire dans notre
deuxième priorité c'est vraiment d'aller
chercher des travailleurs expérimentés à
l'étranger et de recruter des talents
donc on veut amener des gens ici qui
vont eux qui m'ont vraiment avant les
talents pour remplir nos besoins ici de
pénurie du marché pourrait on a un on va
avoir un point 5 millions à peu près
dans plus de l'emploi disponible en 2026
20% des emplois vont être comblés par
l'immigration donc il faut qu'on aille
chercher les talents dont on a besoin
pour remplir ces postulats et donc faut
augmenter l'immigration peut baisser
l'immigration ne pense pas on veut
accueillir des gens qui vont rencontrer
les besoins du marché
donc c'est dans ce sens-là convaincant
le travail mais ce que points contre âge
par exemple les étudiants internationaux
dans votre politique aujourd'hui vous
parler des étudiants internationaux s
qui est pas un conte traces de votre
démarche avec celle du ministre de
l'immigration si montchanin barrette qui
veut réformer resserrer les critères par
exemple de programme de l'expérience
québécoise
en fait c'est pas du tout contradictoire
parce qu'on parle de deux choses qui
sont très différents dans notre cas et
ils se mangeaient les barrettes étaient
à la table on a travaillé cette vision
là avec tous les ministres
y compris plus particulièrement le
ministère de l'économie et le ministère
de l'immigration parce que sont vraiment
les deux grandes réformes qu'on a
actuellement dans le gouvernement
et ce n'est pas du tout contradictoire
parce que sont venus chercher
on va les chercher des étudiants qui
vont venir étudier ici qui vont être
franchisé qui vont s'intégrer au marché
du travail et qui après leurs études
auront toutes les compétences les
qualifications en force de leurs études
pour rencontrer les besoins du marché et
il ya aussi beaucoup d'étudiants qui
viennent étudier ici qui ne veulent pas
nécessairement s'installer au québec
non qu'ils retournent dans leur pays
c'est la grande majorité en fait qu'ils
retournent dans leur pays d'origine le
garder mais je voudrais oui et non
monsieur fillion parce que justement
j'arrive je suis allée être femme une
mission au maroc juste avant justement
en été et j'ai rencontré plusieurs
ministres au niveau du gouvernement du
maroc et ses ministres ont étudié ici au
québec
wen aux universités et il nomme que du
bien à dire du québec et ils ont les
bras grands ouverts pour justement faire
affaire avec le québec
donc quand ils retournent dans leur pays
ils ont cette ouverture très très très
grande de faire affaire avec le québec
de venir investir au québec et ils
vendent de québec international donc il
devient les ambassadeurs pour nous est
ce que pointent un danger ce le dit avec
les politiques en matière d'immigration
récente de votre gouvernement de
modifier cette perception du québec et
que de l'étranger on a l'impression que
les portes sont moins ouvertes au québec
pas du tout pas du tout parce que je
vous dirais que je suis en contact mois
avec les 27 délégués on note d'ailleurs
0,6 et madame un morceau never les bars
il ya quelques semaines de chicago et la
perception n'est pas du tout ça la
perception est vraiment on est une terre
d'accueil on veut avoir les gens ici et
dans cette vision là qu'ont annoncé
aujourd'hui c'est justement ça qu'on
veut faire
on va passer juste aller chercher des
talents mais on veut aussi ouvrir
l'international aux ans aux études quant
aux écoles d'enseignement aux
universités on veut aussi l'ouvrir à nos
jeunes donc pousser nos jeunes à se
sensibiliser à l'international et allez
allez visiter aussi mi temps je termine
avec les cibles vous demandé au délégué
puis aux représentations vous allez
donner des cibles une reddition de
compte pour les délégués oui ça les
concerne
mais quand je suis arrivé en poste
filion j'ai signé des lettres demandant
une certaine les délégués des nouveaux
délégués comme il est les deux mandats
c'était vraiment presque des lettres
philosophiques nous c'est costaud qu'on
veut faire nous on va avoir des
résultats à l'international donc nous la
demande
ça va ça va ça va vraiment être des
lettres magna va avoir des objectifs
spécifiques
on va reprendre on va demander des
résultats parce qu'on économique
oui économiques financiers en fait dans
tous les sujets la main d'oeuvre les
contrôles et les l'épaule et contrôler
les ententes universitaires économiques
wi fi nancer parce que le but
encore une fois c'est vraiment tout le
monde doit travailler dans le même sens
vous allez chercher des investisseurs
pour les amnisties créer des postes et
augmenter les exportations
merci bien madame giroux mais ce désir
merci on va